from the International Monetary Fund a
stark warming this is a crisis like no
other which means there is substantial
uncertainty about the impact it will
have on people's lives and livelihoods
as unemployment lines grow around the
world is manufacturing grains to halt in
many sectors as businesses are forced to
close the economic impact of the Kovach
crisis is biting the IMF issues regular
reports on the global financial
situation three months ago they were
predicting widespread growth coronavirus
has radically changed the landscape we
are projecting global growth in 2020 to
fall to minus 3% now this is a downgrade
of 6.3% egde points from January 2020 a
major revision over a very short period
of time this makes the great lockdown
the worst recession since the Great
Depression and far worse than the global
financial crises one of the biggest jobs
will come in the European euro zone
which is expected to take a hit of 7.5%
the US where the president is pushing to
reopen the economy is looking at a
contraction of nearly 6% Japan 5.2
percent down the seam as Latin America
in China where the pandemic began and
has begun to reopen its economy it's
expected to record growth of just over
1% the IMF is predicting that if things
don't deteriorate there will be a
rebound for the global economy in 2021
but one economist warns that might be
short-lived I think you're going to run
into a lot of headwinds in terms of the
kind of the drag that's gonna come from
all of that the big shock that's
happened over the past quarter in terms
of bankruptcies in terms of lost jobs
and that is gonna weigh quite heavily on
demand and that is why governments and
central banks have been stepping up
stimulus to try and give the economy
this extra boost when it comes out of
this shock that's been induced by these
shutdowns one area seriously impacted
the airline industry it's in its
passenger numbers dropped by half
globally Airlines now think they'll lose
more than
three-hundred billion dollars this year
much more than expected the IMF is
urging countries to work together to
beat the pandemic saying there is no
trade-off between saving lives and
saving livelihoods Allen Fisher al
Jazeera Virginia